so hi bb rexa hello how are you
good how are you i'm good so sabotage is
out today
yeah so what do you do on release day
like do you have any rituals like how do
you experience release day when you
rinse the song
when you release an album oh i'm working
i'm doing interviews all day yeah yeah i
mean in terms of
but i mean in terms of your feelings
like what going into a day like this
like
now that's out there for the world to
hear like what goes through your mind
yeah excited i'm nervous um
i felt like honestly i feel like
throwing up this morning
that's a good reaction well because it's
like you know i've been like working on
this album for about like
two i worked on the album for two years
i've been sitting on it for three
because the pandemic happened
um and it's just really uh it's a lot of
pressure
it's stressful it's a sophomore album
um it's just a lot um it's scary
uh so you know it's it's like i wanted
to do well
um but then also i'm excited because i'm
just i love the song so much sabotage is
one of my favorite songs on the album
yeah and it's so representative of my
life so i just love being real with my
fans
yeah why did you want to release the
song before the album came out
i feel like there are like there are
some records on the album that are
so honest and true to me that um
that sabotage is something that is like
so honest and i just feel like it's so
representative of what the album is and
what
and what the and what i'm going through
as a human being
yeah does a song like this help you um
recognize when you are
self sabotaging yourself like do you
recognize it in your own life now
i mean i do it all the time i was like
i'm gonna eat so well
and i'm gonna like not i'm gonna have a
good diet and
um um one of my friends um
you know got fully vaccinated and was
like oh and i'm getting my vaccine today
and she was like
can i come over like i was like okay
sure fine so she came over and we
ordered pizza
and that is definitely not part of the
healthy eating um
so that was definitely as you could say
a sabotage moment
um but you know that's what life's all
about and then you pick yourself back up
right do you have someone in your life
that like calls you out
oh man everybody around me
like oh like today i ordered a croissant
but i didn't eat it
um yeah and my team was like no
you don't want to eat that um when i'm
like stressed i want to just eat
whatever
is bad whatever is around me that's bad
i'll eat it
yeah and you already mentioned it but i
mean yeah a sophomore album
does it feel like more pressure than the
debut album yeah
100 yeah but um in the other day it's
like what i've learned in my career is
i've had so many songs like
it's my career has been so weird it
hasn't followed like a path or like a
you know like a like a like a like a
normal trajectory like it doesn't
it didn't it's like one plus one equals
like my career was just like
i put out so many songs that i'm really
blessed that have been successful and
then so many that haven't been
and you just never know what is going to
click with fans but what i've learned
personally is that it's the songs that
are the most honest
and meaningful and like truthful and
like um
that's what i feel like has clicked with
my fans the most um
but in the other day i'm like you know
um i'm i always make music i will always
write music
and life is about ups and downs and in
the day it's like yeah it's stressful
you want something to do well but like
it all depends on like where the world's
at
um how good the songs were how relatable
they are
the climate like it's just so many
things that you can't control
and you have to just do your yeah and
speaking of that honesty better mistakes
is one of those songs that i love it's
very frank i love it but why did you
want to call the album better mistakes
um i want to talk about the album better
mistakes because i thought that you know
when i was like in my 20s
i was like okay um i'm gonna like turn
30 and everything's gonna makes like i'm
gonna get
you know grow up and everything's gonna
make so much more sense i'll have no
more anxiety i'll figure everything out
everything will be great and then as you
grow up you're like
oh like i don't know i still don't know
the answer to most
things in this universe but i i know
more
and hopefully i make just better
decisions and you still make mistakes as
an adult
but you make better mistakes or that's
what you hope to make is better mistakes
so you know instead of going for like 10
glasses of the liquor you go for a
couple of glasses of red wine and hope
that it doesn't end up being a crazy
night no but
i think that um yeah like
um just making better mistakes or trying
to make better mistakes in my life and
learn from them
um and being in a becoming
you know an actual adult being right
it's a weird thing yeah to become an
adult i'm like i'm like
what is going like huh i'm 37
i'm 37 i still feel like i'm an adult
literally like
we're like ha like it's so crazy it's so
crazy
because like in your 20s you can get
away with it the second you turn 30
you're like
it's like no more like you can't like
you just
yeah i don't know i don't want to grow
up yeah
either so we're out we're we're three
weeks away from the album coming out
right i think that's
correct yeah three weeks so is it done
like can you if for some reason you
decide no i want to change something can
you change anything at this point is it
locked in
um i mean i could do whatever i want but
i don't know how it affects
how that if there's like a lot of things
in play
so we get a lot of pushback from my
management and label
um again i mean i am very like
whatever like i in the day it's about
the art
but i probably will get yelled at um but
i think i've come to the point where i'm
just like i just want to get this
project out i'm so over having it and
listening to it
on to like i'm in like not even in this
world with that right now
that's what's gonna say like what's the
hard thing to say like okay it's done
or it's more like oh god it's okay now
i'm like yeah i'm like just get this
out please put this outside it's been
three years
you know so i'm like just get this out
so i can like move on with the next
yeah i just want to work on my next
album like i'm going to be on
so over this one like i love it to death
but yeah
did you find like say the songs you were
doing three years ago like you know at
the beginning of the process
are very different than the songs you
did towards the end of it
yeah like you know that's the thing is
like that's why it gets
tough because right like sacrifice which
is the only dance song on the album was
put in last second it's the last song
that was stored in there yeah
yeah so look when the album started was
like was break my heart myself it was uh
my dear love
it was um empty it was
death row it was it's all the guitar
based stuff with a little bit of hip-hop
influence
it was sabotage but with the ballad like
but it still worked in the
you know it was like these darker themed
records you know like with darker lyrics
and tight
and dark pop like titles and stuff and
then as the album went on i'm like
oh i want to do a dance song like it's
so fun like i'm depressed and
quarantined i don't want to be
listening to these sad songs anymore and
then my friend was like i have this idea
of this hook um but it's called
sacrifice and i think it's cool because
like you kind of like it's darker like
lyrically and that's like the vibe
you're going for it's like okay i'll
listen to i kind of love the title
um so he sent me like the hook and i was
like oh my god this is
amazing like i died for this song and i
was like ah put it on the album whatever
um there's like you know there's like a
couple of songs from the album that are
just like last
like minute stranglers i was like okay
just throw those on
um but probably should have been on the
next album but um
yeah i just go with the flow yeah yeah
and so he sacrificed that music video
what was that
fake blood like what was that process
like well it was inspired by blade the
movie blade
um yeah and um the fake blood it's just
water with food coloring
was it like was it sticky like was it
hard getting off water it was just
uh my hands were red for like a week and
then my hair turned pink
oh that was really interesting so yeah
it was interesting and it was really
cold yeah it was freezing
yeah it looked amazing yeah end result
looked amazing that's all that matters
i'm really proud of that video i love it
i know a lot of
a lot of people are kind of like you
know i could have went in much safer
route with that or route like but i just
wanted to do something different
and um you know like do a reference to a
90s movie about vampires i just wanted
to have fun i didn't want to do the
obvious like standing there in like a
bikini like pop video like
all like you know glammed out like hey
nothing wrong with that
but just i wanted something different
yeah absolutely i feel like everyone
needs some funny music now like now that
we're
almost out of this painting
now as my as my most depressing songs
come out
you know what okay as long as people
you know as long as people are sad
they're gonna want sad songs and that's
gonna be forever
as long as people wanna dance which will
be forever they're gonna want dance
songs
so they're you know for me the my most
important thing is like
just um being honest being vulnerable
being real um and just
making songs that are true to me and as
long as i'm true to myself
um no matter how a song does
as long as you're true to yourself like
then you really have no regrets
right yeah that's a great way to look at
it and the collaborations on here
are amazing like travis barker doji cat
had dollar sign rick ross
was there any of them that you really
had to fight for like does a real
struggle make happen or do they all just
click
um i think you know i shot i shot a
video little uzi and that was kind of
hard to make happen i had to fly to new
york
um yeah so that was kind of tough
because he's you know
doing his thing living in his own world
but he was so chill so nice
um and uh really supportive of the
record which i love
and um but i will tell you the one song
that like i've actually had like it's
been so fun
is break my heart myself with travis
barker like we just shot the music video
and he truly is
an incredible musician like
in the music video and i was just blown
away
um and it was really really cool and um
you know
that was really nice yeah i was checking
out your social media too i loved um
your stuff at wrestlemania what was that
experience like like the hulk hogan hug
oh my god i i was so star trek when i
met hulk hogan
like he popped out like he was like in
the corner and he popped out and i was
like
oh my god um you know like i grew up
watching like his show and then also
like i love the rock
you know wayne johnson when he did the
eye
yeah yeah yeah the eyebrows yeah cooking
can you do that yeah
can you do that i can yeah
um but like but like you know um yeah
uh it was really cool being there
because i grew up watching wrestlemania
and like watching wrestling wwe so it
was really cool to be part of that and
then i got to watch bad bunny
um and he killed it because he did him
he had a match and
um got to meet him backstage he was
playing dominoes it was really cute
um put the picture together and he was
so awesome and i just had so much fun
yeah yeah it looked amazing i feel like
it'd be a whole like
interesting world behind the scenes too
it was crazy imagine like that stage
just a whole bunch of like naked
wrestlers with like like big wrestlers
like old
baby oil on their body yeah a lot of oil
yeah it was hilarious when i spoke to
the guy one of the
guys there was like i want to learn how
to wrestle he's like we're so down i'd
be like that would be so cool
and i would be remiss if i didn't
mention um the social media posts you
did like asking your fans to post like
the
unfold like no no photoshop um photos
like they were actually got that was
incredible like were you surprised at
the reaction that you
got to that yeah like i was shook
you know um yeah i feel like people are
really
swanting real yeah um
you know we live in a world like even
for me like i'm gonna be honest like
like we photoshop filters all the time
like you know i use filters on my
instagram i love it like you know
because i feel like the pressure of
looking a certain way
but i feel like now we've come to a
point where we just want real and i
always find myself struggling with that
because i'm like oh i want to be perfect
and i want to look perfect and i want
people to like like me
but then i'm like i want to just be
myself i don't have to always post
pictures of me like
being photoshopped and like with no
makeup like with makeup on all the time
like i want to just
be myself and i feel like people are
like really love that like people like
are craving that
you know because it's like you have so
many like unrealistic body standards for
men
and women and it's okay like i think i
think we need to like
it's just it's too much that's the thing
like i mean it's a problem society
everywhere but i mean
do you find it frustrating that it's so
much in hollywood too like i don't know
if it was just a coincidence that
you did that after khloe kardashian's
posters where she said you know she's
gonna keep photoshopping stuff
and people shouldn't judge her but do
you find it frustrating to see that
like to the extent that it is in
hollywood i mean like
uh you could i feel like dude i my
motto in life is do whatever you want
like whatever makes you happy
if you want to get your tits done i'm
sorry if i don't know if i could say
that oops
i don't if you want to get your bus
boobs done your booty done you want to
get lipo
you don't want to get it you don't
believe in it you want to get filler you
want to get botox you want to
whatever makes you happy um do it
um i just think that there are i like
when people are
real and have honest moments you know so
like
uh to me it's like
if you wanna photoshop your pictures go
ahead like why not like do what you have
to do
we are in entertainment you know so if
we
posted videos and pictures of ourselves
every day with no makeup on
i think people would like it's just like
you can't make any of everybody happy
like if i were to post
i post a picture with myself with no
makeup we're like why are your under
eyes so dark you know
and it's like you just can't win so you
have to make yourself happy and do
whatever makes you happy
whether you want to be a size zero a
size 14 a size 20
um get your booty done whatever you want
to do just do what makes you happy
because you will never make
everyone happy and that's everybody has
opinions
you'll some people will love you some
people will hate you some people
yeah you can't wait you're set to live
your life thing that i've learned is
that you've got to love yourself
yeah everybody in the world could tell
you the most beautiful person or the
ugliest person and
and if you believe that you're the most
beautiful person that's all that matters
you know what i mean
yeah very well said i i can say like
pleasure talking to
today bb and i will say the album is
worth the wait it was worth the wait for
three years to hear it yeah it was
really enjoyable they had to listen to
that album so congratulations i can't
wait for everyone to hear it
thank you so much thank you